many of you have shared some great back
to school pictures with us
keep them coming because we love to see
them here are a few of our
own here we have aaliyah how adorable is
she in her outfit for back to school her
cute little dress there thank you so
much for sending that in
there we go and then we also have stevie
look at his adorable mask with the
planets
solar system space shuttle we love it
keep it going stevie we hope you had a
great first day
and please share your pictures with us
you could see them on air the email
addresses
pics that's pix 8newsnow.com and we have
some photos to share with you ted in
christian
ted likes to do this every year i like
to always surprise you guys
with your own pics and talk with your
moms and everything else too
so here's all of us i thought i'd bring
this back up so cute
christian over here on the left i don't
know why you thought this isn't a cute
pic
hey check out the hair i mean it's cute
i'm surprised i didn't like topple over
no no this is that's great okay
that's a great horrible christian were
you first grade
that was a first grade picture yes that
was about seven
six seven years old oh yeah that's
awesome and ted's always ted you're
blocking your own photo
yeah this is so cute yeah for a good
reason oh my gosh
the hair we all had awkward here i like
you okay so this is kj this is you
and i want to recreate this shop okay i
want to go back with you
on the school bus what you're almost you
got that almost that that shirt right
there
we could totally i was getting ready to
get on the bus in south berry
connecticut
i was five or six you know first day
yesterday i like the little pose that
she's doing yeah i know that that's
totally yeah
we should have brought her backpack
today okay there's me they're telling me
to wrap so it's good
it's so